السيد الرئيس ، هل يمكنك أن تخبرني بماذا أنت
في المجموعة التي أنت معها الآن
هناك مسلحون
وما هي نيتك
إذا أخطأ الروس
فقط مساعدتي هنا هنا هذا هو
الكلاشينكوف القصير
الذي سمح لي
به للتو  300
فرد من كتيبة الدفاع
الإقليمي ولدينا
مدفعان
رشاشان ولدينا
أكثر أو أقل هذا
ليس لدينا أي مدفعية ثقيلة
وليس لدينا دبابات وليس لدينا
حاملة شخصية مسلحة لأننا  لقد
أطلقنا هذه العملية
منذ يومين فقط ، لكننا أنشأناها
ليومين هذه هي الحياة الطويلة للأشخاص
الذين يريدون تجنيدها في الكتيبة
ولكن ليس لدينا ما يكفي من الأسلحة
لذلك وهذا هو الحد الوحيد.  لماذا
دفاع الإشارة هو أن
الناس العاديين لم يكونوا في بعض الأحيان في الجيش
ويبقون في الطابور الآن للانضمام إلينا
هذا هو أه
ملموس للغاية ورائع للغاية
كيف يكره الشعب الأوكراني
بوتين وكيف أننا ضد
العدوان الروسي هذا هو  واضح جدا